sie gehen gerne gemeinsam essen sie
lieben die deftige einfalt der
bayerischen küche sie schützen die
bekömmliche vielfalt asiatischer
kochkunst sie lieben running sushi bei
ihnen steht quantität vor qualität
sie entscheiden sich beim bestehen in
der regel dreimal um und ändern
mindestens einmal die beilage sie
starren beim essen lieber auf ein
laufband als sich mit dem partner zu
unterhalten weil der ehe immer anderer
meinung ist dann haben wir genau das
richtige für sie vergessen sie den
hopfen wird vom hinter einer vergessen
sie saburo vom tokio san hier kommt
running schweinsbraten das sind
bayerische schmankerl in neuem gewand
und am laufenden band
[Musik]
mist gewachsen
ist blut und leberwurst saftige kalt so
laden voll
und ganz schweinsbraten mit knödel kraut
und kutteln schlagen sie zu bis ihnen
der klosterhardter aus den ohren sind
da fühlt man sich immer psychologisch
benötigt was man möglichst nicht mehr
frei ist wenn man vertraut
[Musik]
running schweinsbraten das ist das beste
aus bayern und asien vereint
tschuldigung was kunden doch bitte jetzt
nur aus asien
das laufband
[Musik]
[Applaus]